el congelamiento político de Irak cumple
un año a pesar de las frecuentes
protestas y las decenas de Muertos
acumulados el escenario no parece
cambiar pronto el parlamento está
fraccionado y el país se perfila
afrontar el 2023 sin presupuesto ni
reformas necesarias en este contexto sus
habitantes se muestran agobiados
Porque no tenemos un presupuesto todavía
los jóvenes nos hemos visto muy
afectados por el aumento en el precio de
los bienes el dólar y los precios de los
alimentos
los analistas culpan a la desigualdad
como causa del actual clima social
los ciudadanos definitivamente están
sufriendo debido a la falta de una
distribución justa en la riqueza hay
empleados que reciben salarios
increíblemente altos mientras que
algunos ahora han sido afectados por la
situación económica
las elecciones legislativas anticipadas
de octubre de 2021 fueron una conquista
del pueblo tras las protestas de 2019
pero no la solución esperada el clérigo
montada al sadar ganó los comicios y el
parlamento boicoteó sus propuestas para
formar un gobierno el bloque renunció a
sus bancas y trasladó la disputa a la
calle Sí así así el país atraviesa una
crisis política que afecta a la gente
Todos están cansados esta junta corrupta
ha llegado a este país donde no hay
lugar para la vida no hay más Esperanza
que La retirada de esta junta
Irak completa 365 días con destino
político incierto y una economía
condicionada por las secuelas de la
guerra